[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
one of the greatest things about
fortnite is the storyline the thing is
we all have slightly different versions
of the story
because epic games never actually
confirms anything to us
and instead leaves us to make whatever
story we prefer
in our own personal canon but out there
on the island in both chapter one and
two
are mysteries no one can solve our
questions no one can answer
or maybe you can slap code adamaru in
the star to support these shenanigans
and let's try and crack
these cases here are 10 unsolved
mysteries found in fortnite
[Music]
for our first mystery we're going back
to fortnite chapter one
season zero how many of you were playing
back then
what season did you guys start playing
well back in season zero an easter egg
could be found
which nobody can understand at all
remember the old location many of us
called containers
well in there we could find this
abomination a completely unique item
which looks like a shrunken down device
within a briefcase or rather luggage for
the entire chapter we looked for answers
but
none ever arrived it looks like a
cabbage machine
reduced in size kinda like what they do
in the ant-man movie
now almost three years later and it
looks like we will never
ever find out what this item represented
maybe it was foreshadowing a miniature
ray gun or a shrinking machine
or even hint to a story and save the
world i need you guys to crack this case
i've been looking for the suitcase again
in chapter two but alas i can't
please keep an eye out for it and tell
me what you think it's for
[Music]
for our next entry let's jump forward to
present day
as i'm saying this it's chapter 2 season
2 and the doomsday device is moments
away from changing the island yet again
all around the island are various groups
of stone
well did you notice that some of these
stone sights are man-made with huge
slabs of stone positioned very carefully
they regularly have chest spawns too the
ritual site near camp cod is the most
complete with seven stones
surrounding a central pillar it kinda
resembles the rune spots from chapter
one and as we all know
those things were very important the
thing to note about these stone ritual
sites is their
carvings a sun or maybe an eye some kind
of wind
and a flame here's where these things
get interesting
remember back in chapter one and the
polar peak mountain
that slowly started to thaw and inside
was a prisoner
upstairs was a meeting room which shows
all these symbols
which represent different gods or
deities it looked like
the fire king was imprisoned by the ice
king and now back in chapter 2
the references of these deities continue
could this one represent
a tornado maybe a sun fueled drought
or maybe we should expect fire one
thing's for sure
these ritual sites have more to offer
during chapter two
can you solve this mystery before it's
revealed
[Music]
at number eight on our list is the
almighty truckasaurus
he's been with us since day zero and
whether you call him a transformer maybe
optimus prime
or trochasaurus like me you're certain
to recognize him
in chapter one this chap could be found
hanging about
outside the rv park he was completely
made from vehicles
except for his walking stick this guy
was ready for retirement
when season 9 arrived truckasaurus
received new body parts from brand new
vehicles
and by the end of the season he was
lifting his walking stick to the skies
because it was now a sword then in the
final season of chapter one truckasaurus
lost one arm to mimic what happened to
the singularity mech
man that live event was brilliant when
chapter two arrived and we all traveled
through the black hole we ran around to
see if we could find truckasaurus
and he was here he was lurking in the
depths of the sea
just below steamy stacks miraculously he
now has
both his arms again and his legs are
either ripped apart
or they are hidden under the sand i'm
calling it now truckasaurus will move
again in the future of fortnite
but what will that mean for all of us if
we look at the facts
he's actually foreshadowed the mech
event in season nine and he's
potentially told us about the flood in
chapter two
truckasaurus knows something one day he
will wake up from his slumber
so watch out heyman and tony stank the
iron pipe man
truckasaurus will reclaim this island
our next mystery is camp cod i'm sure
you visited that place regularly and
noticed that it's a military stronghold
with weapon drills going on but it's
also the home of the collector
someone here is locating items from the
original chapter one map
and bringing them back home to camp cot
they have found the old water fountain
from westworld
there's the sign from lonely lodge and
there's parts of the old sunny steps poi
here
we can find the seats from the old dusty
diner and the og meteor landing spot
and check this out the clock from the
old tilted towers
man riding the fields so the question
remains why are they collecting all this
stuff together
from the og island and this thing needs
our attention
why is there a fake hot watch here
nobody's falling for that my friend
let's keep an eye on this place and what
the collector finds next
could they track down truckasaurus or
maybe transfer the hidden derberger and
pizza pit mascots here
or maybe they'll go for the real hut
watch just up the road
we shall see
next a real mystery in plain sight what
the heck is the relationship between
links and meowsles let's go back in time
to understand this
back when we got the snow by on when the
ice smashed into the island back in 2018
one of the loading screens revealed lynx
a techno-savvy secret agent
with a love of cats what many didn't
notice was in the background
we could see a picture of meowthels over
a year before he made it into the game
and to confirm this take a look at
meowso's muscles
a tattoo of lynx is there for all to see
at this point we can surmise that they
know each other and meowsles is
completely smitten like a kitten
over lynx so let's go further down this
rabbit hole
in the season two trailer mousels is
referred to as six years old
that is in cat years by the way making
his real age
about mid 30s and maybe even 40 years
old
in human years so when i checked into
links and found out that the internet
thinks she's 16
well i got scared but things could have
got weird
but i'm not going to let that happen
here what if meowsles he's actually
links his father
that would explain why she's slightly
obsessed with cats and that would also
explain why he has a tattoo of his
daughter
i did some more digging and found that
lynx is based on a real life person
called kitty plays
and she is 27 years of age this is
probably closer to it
as she has tattoos i don't know many 16
year olds with tattoos
maybe you do that would make the ages
much closer anyway and much more
believable as a couple
and right now in game we've seen that
lynx has potentially
been taken out by midas but we're not
quite certain on that
so now it's your turn can you solve this
one what will happen when meowsles finds
out
and is links really gone here's some
music to help you think while you
write in the comments below
[Music]
here's a great one those damn hatches
back in chapter one a single hatch could
be found in wailing woods
and then after the volcano erupted it
was moved to the side of sunny steps
for years we had no idea what this was
for
and then a second one appeared in the
snow biome which was encased in ice and
impossible to get to once we did get
through that ice
it did nothing at all fast forward to
chapter two and this creepy island here
hides another one of those hatches under
a shack
by the way let's note the suspicious
telescopes hiding in bushes here
this place is a little questionable not
long after this another hatch was found
near retail row underneath a bush and a
few trees
and then a third bunker was found out in
the sea
right now we can't swim down to check
that one but if there's a flood
and somehow we have underwater swimming
mechanics then we may be closer to
answering this one
but the question still remains what are
the hatches made for
we need your detective skills to solve
this one
[Music]
another mystery about chapter one
incoming we all know that hut watch is
the most important update ever in
fortnight history
well there's also something which is
just as awesome do you remember the
story of the rock people
over three seasons the rock story kept
us on edge
we first saw rock the dwayne johnson
built before his partner sharon stone
appeared close by
after the volcano knocked both down they
somehow rebuilt themselves and over
weeks and months
finally made it back to one another we
really should mention here that fortnite
island can bring inanimate objects to
life
but that's a mystery all of its own the
following season the two set up a farm
and had a child together named kid rock
who once old enough
left home for a walk one day we watched
him cartwheel and frolic until he saw a
flower
that needed to be picked right away upon
grabbing it
he began to fall luckily a little dog
rock viola
saw him and somehow pulled him to safety
it was a great moment
but before the story could continue we
were thrown through a black hole
and that family was never seen again
i checked the island all rock formations
and nothing is there
whatever happened will they ever return
[Music]
okay onto the top three and we are
starting with kevin the cube
and his mystery where did he come from
and what is his purpose and more
importantly what will kevin do
in chapter two when kevin was created by
the pink lightning bolt in the sky
we could have never foreseen his impact
on us all his live event which showed us
an alternative universe
blew our minds to such a point we
erected memorials at his birth and death
spots
this guy was important in chapter 2
kevin has been boiled
down and seemingly used as nuclear power
the case is wide open can you answer the
two burning questions
who made kevin and what will happen next
over in save the world kevin the cube
was revealed to be the storm king we
know that isn't the case in battle
royale
unless hmm maybe put a pin in that
anyway if you successfully predict the
future in the comments below and do not
edit your answer
i'm down to add you as a friend play a
few games together i'll gift you
something
there are so many seasons in front of us
what would you do
to advance the story of kevin
at number two on the list is a mystery
we've been trying to understand
forever the mystery of the seven
without the seven we would still
perpetually be looped on the original
island
which sounds pretty good right now i
wouldn't mind being back there so far
three members of the group have been
identified
the first the visitor who landed via
meteor impact back in season four
of chapter one he didn't last long he
was seemingly lost during the rocket
event
the second member of the seven looks to
be singularity who protected the island
from a monster attack in season nine
although it was never confirmed to be
singularity the female visitor skin
known as the paradigm released shortly
after singularity's heroics
and uses the exact same character model
am i jumping to conclusions
are they the same person if she was the
one piloting the mech that day
she is now somewhere in space after
flying out of the atmosphere preceding
season
x and speaking of season x a third
visitor arrived
the scientist who first needs to be
celebrated as a legit thick boy
thick with four c's the scientist
continued the work of the original
visitor and completed the rocket leading
to the cycle being broken
what isn't clear is if the other members
of the seven piloted the other
spaceships
in that event or were they all him will
we ever find out
and now in chapter two the seven have
seemingly vanished once again
until this moment arrived it was a split
second but a carving on a tree
displayed three of the seven so now my
fellow detectives
do your thing who will be the next
member of the seven to be revealed
and how will they impact the story i'll
keep checking back here regularly to see
your theories as i'm planning on
bringing back story theories next season
i'll try smash together some of your
work
to make something epic each week
we've made it to number one on the list
and i think you know what it has to be
the redacted bunker since day one of
chapter 2 we've waited
and waited and watched and waited
at this place for something to happen
but alas nothing
ever did we have nothing at all in terms
of information we are literally guessing
what will happen
some people believe a slurp army is
being created behind those doors
other people see this door as a link to
the save the world game mode under
potential crossover
and others believe the door will open to
welcome tanks and
other machinery where do you stand on
this
will we ever find out what is in that
bunker will we ever know what this place
is called
at the moment we just call it redacted
my bet
is that this place will be pivotal in
season 10 of chapter two
so that'll be about three years from now
oh i don't think i can wait that long
but i'm gonna try
let's all keep waiting here so there we
have it ten
unsolved mysteries in fortnite battle
royale please let me know if you have
any more of these and we'll make a part
two
on screen now are those legends who are
kind enough to support me in the
fortnight shop
i really appreciate you thank you so
much especially those who've stuck with
me for seasons now
if you're watching this on release week
have a great time at the event and if
you're watching from the future
laugh about all the myths we were unable
to solve back in 2020
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure see you next time
[Music]